- Good evening, everyone.
I know it has been long
day for all of you,
but I hope that re:Invent has
started great for all of you.
And we do have a exciting topic to cover.
As start of this session
where we will be talking about
how we can break the legacy barrier
and accelerate the
modernization using GenAI.
I'm Anand Bilgaiyan,
I'm a senior specialist
partner solution architect
for enterprise transformation
and I'm joined by Sree.
- Hi, good evening, everyone.
My name is Sreekumar Nair,
I'm a senior specialist
solution architect, migration
and modernization at AWS and
I'm based out of Singapore.
- Thank you Sree. So let's get started.
Many of our customers, for them,
their digital transformation
is a key priority
to support their business growth, right?
But the legacy IT applications
and the landscape becomes the barrier
for their business growth.
Now, the modernizing these
legacy applications can be
complex and they may warrant
significant amount of the cost
as well as the effort.
And that's where we are going to look
how we can accelerate the modernization
of those legacy application using some
of the architectural
methodologies, best practices,
and the power of genAI coming all together
to transform those legacy
applications, right?
So a quick agenda,
however, next one hour going to look like.
So we are going to talk about
a use case from monolith
to microservices where we
are considering monolithic
as a representation of
the legacy application
and the microservices based
cloud native architecture as a
to be targeted state.
And then we are going to look upon
how we can converge from this
legacy architectures in terms
of monolithic to the
microservices using some
of the architectural methodologies
and then how we can leverage
GenAI to accelerate that.
Since this is a level 400 session,
so we will be covering
the different demos right
toward the different modernization phase
as part of this session, right?
So let me first introduce
a sample application,
which is a Unicorn Ecommerce Store,
which representing a
monolithic legacy application
for our session.
And we will be converging this
into the more modernization
based architecture
throughout our session.
And in the end we will be
having a modernized state
of this Unicorn store application.
Now, what are some of the
business capabilities?
This standard e-commerce
monolith application have.
Just have a look on that.
So it's a standard
web-based e-com application
which allow users to log in,
then search the different Unicorn icon
and then do the check on
their specification pricing.
And then based on their need,
they can actually select
these Unicorn icon, add them
to the cart, review the cart,
and then provide their payment as well
as the shipment details.
And then they can just place the order.
A standard flow like what we all use to
do on any typical e-commerce
application, right?
So let's look the function flow,
what we just saw from this Unicorn store
monolith application, right?
So users log in, they start
search for the products
and then based on their
requirement, they add those products
or item to the cart and
then they make the payments.
And then after the payment,
they actually place the order.
Now these functionality
has been built using a standard
.net core 3.1 framework
and what are the properties
this application have
which make it kind of a legacy
monolithic architecture.
If we look upon the different
modules which support these
different business capabilities
like cart, like payments,
like checkout, like the
product catalog, they all are,
these all modules are built
and bundled as part of
the single application.
Now we have looked this flow
from the business perspective,
let's revisit the same application
and its property from the
architecture perspective as well.
So again, as I mentioned,
this application comprises
of different modules.
We support the different
business capabilities
around the cart products and
the payments and the order.
All these products, all these
modules already are bundled
as part of the same application,
mostly also leveraging
the same common database.
Now what's happening there
is the single application is
doing everything,
all the business capabilities
are being supported
by this application and
that's where it is having lot
of hidden complexities.
The different modules,
they all are dependent to
each other, maybe referring
to each other implicitly.
Now these are some of the
properties which make this
application monolithic.
And now let's look into
what are the different challenges this
application will have.
So one of the challenges
around the scalability,
let's say we are running
to the Black Friday sale
or the Cyber Monday sale
where we are anti anticipating the two x
or three x amount of orders.
Now we want to scale the order module
to handle these Cyber Monday
or maybe the Black Friday event.
What we rather end up scaling this
entire application, right?
Because all order modules
like other module is bundled
as part of the single application.
Now what that causes, it causes
the operational challenges.
It also increase the overall
cost of the deployment, right?
Because you're actually
deploying the entire application
as a whole, even if you want
to just scale the order module.
The next is the
significant time to change.
So it impact the business agility as well.
Let's suppose the different new features
which need to get released.
Now any feature will warrant to
test this entire application, right?
And then deploy this entire
application into the production.
So it also increase the
overall time to market, right?
And that another challenge
which is imposed by this kind
of monolithic applications are,
is on if any issue in any module
and any part of the
application may bog down
the entire application.
So it also impact your
business continuity.
And apart from that it also impose a lot
of operational challenges
and introduce the technical depth
in your environment, right?
So when we talk about, okay, we understand
what are the challenges of
the monolithic applications.
Now, if we want to modernize that,
the modernization is not a
single step process, right?
Modernization is a phased
approach which required a careful
consideration to transform these
legacy application into the
more modern agile cloud
native architectures.
Now, given a case of this
particular application, right?
If we have to transform or
modernize this application,
what could be the
possible different phases
which we may have to think through
and take to transform into
the more modern state?
Let's have a view on that.
Firs, definitely, the first phase is,
or the first step is to
do a application analysis.
This application analysis
is very, very important
because this application
analysis may give you some of the
properties around the
application which may help you
to take the first step
toward your modernization.
For example, as I mentioned
in the previous slide,
this particular Unicorn store application
is built on .net core 3.1,
which is a older framework.
Now, the first thing is to
improve the overall performance
and the security posture
of my application.
So it's better to transform
this application into the latest
version of the framework, right?
So those kind of insight I
can get via doing the right
application analysis.
Once my application analysis
is done, then I want
to definitely transform my
runtime in the framework so
that I can improve those
performance in the security posture
and make my application
more better in terms
of then introducing the new capabilities
around the modern cloud
native architectures.
Then I definitely have to build
and validate my application
with whatever changes I have
done architecturally from the
framework upgrade standpoint.
And then once that is done, I need
to perform a decomposition analysis
and we will talk much in much
detail about the decomposition
analysis and what are some
of the architectural methodologies
to perform this decomposition analysis.
Once my decommission analysis is done,
what it provide us?
It provide us a identification
of the different services,
in which this monolithic
application could get
transformed or decomposed.
And last but not the least,
once you have identified
those right services,
you start refactoring this application
and then you modernize it
accordingly with the new
architectures, right?
So we are going to look upon
all these different phases,
sorry, we define the right architecture
and then perform the right decomposition
and the refactoring of the application.
And we are going to look upon
all these different seven
phases, how we can perform
these different phases using
the different architectural methodologies
and the capability of genAI, right?
So to perform these different step process
to modernize a legacy application,
we are going to leverage
some of the key genAI based capabilities
provided by AWS.
Now let's look upon those very quickly.
The first one is the Kiro,
which is AI-based IDE,
to accelerate your prototype
into the productions.
Now there be mostly the
developer leverage the code
companion or the AI-based IDE
to perform the vibe coding.
Now we want to get away from
that phase to make, instead
of doing the white coding, we
want to write a viable code
and then we want to go
more into the spec-driven
software development approach
where your prompts become
the specs so that you can
perform a right business analysis
requirement analysis.
And then from there you go
and design your application
according to your requirements
and then from there you
implement those requirements
and then finally you execute
that particular code.
So the end to end lifecycle
or building the software
can be then powered
by using the this ID,
AI-driven ID called Kiro.
Now it has a different capabilities.
The first capability it can help you
to build a new application
using the spec-driven
software development approach,
which I just spoke about.
You can also modify existing
application where you have
to adopt the new change request based on
your business requirement.
That can also be done
using this particular AI
driven IDE Kiro.
And last but not not least, it
also supports the refactoring
and modernizing your existing
application code base.
And we are going to focus on
this particular capability.
Last capability throughout our
session when we go into the
different phases of the modernization.
The next very important
and the key service which we
will be covering in our session
is AWS transform,
which is the first
agentic AI based service
to perform the large scale
migration and modernization.
This particular service has got four
different key capabilities.
The first one is on
around VMware migration
where it can help us to assess
the existing VMware environment,
perform the right networking
design in the context
of migrating those on AWS,
do a right way planning
with the intelligent
grouping of the application.
So effectively migrate
this application cloud.
And last but not least, execute
the actual lift in shift.
The safring capabilities
on the full stack window
modernization, right?
We have released some of the additional
and advanced capabilities
today itself, right?
And our transform has got
more powerful to perform you
end-to-end window
modernization, where along
with the .net modernization means
the .net application transformation.
It also support the modernizing
its associated databases.
So if you have a .net
application, you want
to transform the .net application,
let's say from the legacy .net framework
to the .net eight or .net 10.
Along with that, the associated databases
of this application from the
SQL server can get modernized
into the Amazon Postgres,
Aurora, Aurora Postgres,
the more open source,
the databases which can
significantly improve
your overall cost and give you
the window licensing freedom.
The third is on the
mainframe modernization
where it has got the capability
to perform the mainframe application
modernization assessment
and then you know, do a right
decomposition analysis based
on the domain driven approach.
And then also we have got a new capability
where it can also support all three phases
of mainframe application
modernization form of re-imagining,
replay forming and
refactoring the application
and also helping to the customer
to significantly reduce the testing effort
for the mainframe workload.
And last but not the least,
the custom modernization,
we are not only the .net, you
can transform the, you know,
the application from
Java, from .net to Python
and even your custom application
based on your enterprise
code pattern and the design
patterns architectural pattern
it can adopt and then it can
accordingly perform the
transformation, right?
And we are going to focus
on the window modernization
capability as part of this session
because our Unicorn store
application is a .net based
model application.
Now with that, let's
look into the first phase
of that modernization
workflow, where we want
to perform the application
analysis of the given application
and how AI can help us to
that to that effectively.
So, Sree.
- Alright thank you, Anand.
So Anand has taken you
through the different,
the seven phase approach that
we are gonna talk about today
as well as the Unicorn e-commerce
application as well, right?
So the next step for us
is to use Kiro to actually
look at the Unicorn application itself
and understand its current
architecture, right?
So in the next video
that you're gonna see,
we will open the Unicorn
apps code base in Kiro.
Then we'll using the natural
language query we will ask Kiro
what is the framework
used in the application?
What are the current technical
and business challenges
the application has?
And also explain the architecture
of the application, right?
Once that is done, we will use
that insights which Kiro has given us
to develop a comprehensive modernization
strategy for this application.
Including, you know, short
term quick wins, medium term
service decomposition, as well
as long term architectural transformation.
So the idea is after this
demo, you should be able
to use this methodical approach
within your own applications
and break down those into
manageable scalable services.
So let's go into the demo now.
Alright, so this is the Kiro interface.
You can see the explorer window as well
as the chat window on the right side.
So I'm gonna ask Kiro
to analyze my code base,
determine the .net version used
and explain what are the business
and technical challenges.
So Kiro is thinking going
through the code base.
So it's trying to understand
what is the current version used.
So it says it's .net 3.0.
What is the recommended target?.net eight
because .net 3.0 has
already gone end of life
a few years ago.
Current architecture is a classic monolith
entire application.
It also recommends the key business
and technical challenges
including cloud native limitation.
It highlights the shared
data management issue
because it's using a shared
database across multiple
services, monolith API,
which makes it difficult
to expand their different
business capabilities.
What is the immediate recommendation?
Upgrade to .net eight
short term extract the bounded context,
which we will explain about it later
and medium term go into a complete
microservices architecture.
Yeah, so Kiro has analyzed
the code base and then
provided us with the recommendations.
So next step.
So we have seen that it's using
.net 3.5 framework, right?
And then it's recommending
to upgrade to .net eight.
So the service that we are
gonna use is AWS transform
to upgrade the code base to .net eight.
So what is AWS transform?
Anand briefed you on what it is,
but it is the agent AI
powered service developed
to accelerate enterprise modernization
of .net, VMware Windows
mainframe and more.
So it's based on 19 years of
AWS experience in migration
and modernization using AI agents
to automate complex tasks like
code analysis, assessment,
refactoring, decomposition,
dependency mapping, validation,
as well as transformation
plan for your applications.
So in this particular demo
we will be using the AWS
transform for .net capability
and then there are two ways
that you can use the AWS
transform for .net service,
either using the web
experience or web interface
or using the visual studio
AWS toolkit extension.
So in this demo we'll be
using the visual studio
toolkit extension.
So let's see the demo,
how AWS transform does it.
Before going that, also
want to expand on how
the AWS transform for .net
follows through the three
critical stages, right?
So the first step is the analysis phase.
So basically what it does
is it looks at the existing
Windows dependent application,
identify the components
which needs to be modified
for Linux compatibility.
Next it does goes through the
transformation phase, right?
Where the agents, the
AI agents will convert
the applications into
.net eight applications.
This is where AWS transform
does the heavy lifting.
So it basically handles the
framework upgrade as well
as platform specific code
changes that is required
for the application to run on
Linux, which is .net eight.
So finally it does a validation.
So it ensures that the
transform application functions
correctly before the deployment,
which is key to make sure
that the migration and
modernization is successful.
So how it does this key tasks.
So first is it upgrades
the language version.
So if it finds a outdated
C# code in your application,
what it does is it replaces it with
Linux-compatible C# code.
Next it does upgrade the packages from
a Windows dependent .net framework
to a more Linux compatible, more .net,
which is compatible with Linux.
And third, it rewrites the
code for Linux compatibility.
And finally for open-ended tasks
where you require human intervention,
where the transform is not
able to make the changes,
it provide you a detailed
report of what are the changes
that you need to make so that
you can get the application
build and successfully
run on Linux, right?
So like Anand was explaining earlier,
by modernizing your .net applications,
you can break free from
the Windows dependencies,
reduce cost, and gain
the flexibility of the
Linux environments.
So next, let's see the demo.
So you can see that we have opened up
the Unicorn store in the GitHub
and then now we are gonna
open the Visual Studio code
and then go to the AWS toolkit.
So you need to make sure
that the AWS transform is
connected, authenticated using IAM.
So we have the project opened
on the right side window.
Now we right click on
the, on the project itself
and then go to port solution
with AWS transform option.
So here it shows the target versions.
So you can see .net eight
and .net 10 are available.
So you click on start.
So it opens the AWS
transform hub, which is used
to track the the entire
transformation plan.
So it shows the plan.
So you can either customize the plan
which it provides, or you
can also use the default plan
that transform provides, right?
So customization, you can add more steps.
So it's going through
the transformation plan.
So essentially it tries
to build the application,
make sure all the
dependencies are available,
and then it completes a transformation.
So you can see on the top
that the transformation
has been completed.
Now, you can download the
detailed transformation report.
So in the transformation
report you can see
the packages, it has updated the APIs
it has changed whether it
is a partially successful
transformation or a fully
successful transformation.
In partially successful
transformations, you can go down
and see the project summary
to see are there any build
errors, what are the packages
that are updated?
So you can see the files
that has been changed
to make sure it is Linux compatible.
You can use a diff view of
the files so you can see
what was there and what has been changed.
So you can view that option as well.
And then again, you can
go to the Linux readiness.
So it provides a detailed
report on the Linux readiness.
Again, what are the
current framework stack
that is being used?
You can download the next steps.
So that'll actually tell you
what are the critical errors
that you need to resolve to
make sure this application
is ready to run on Linux.
You can go through validate the steps
to make sure you execute it.
So it provides all the
commands, the changes
that is required before you can do it.
Then you can view the
diffs on all the files
and then you can select all
and you can do an apply changes
which will do an in place
change of all the files.
And then now the
application is, you can see
that it's already on .net eight, right?
So it has been now upgraded
to .net eight version, which
is Linux compatible.
Now it has been built, sorry,
it has been upgraded to .net eight.
Now we need to make sure
that this application
runs successfully, right?
So again, I'm gonna use Kiro
to build that application.
So I'll go into Kiro,
I'm gonna prompt Kiro to
ask what is the .net version
that is being currently used.
So it tells me that now
it is .net eight, right?
Which was our target version
that Kiro suggested earlier.
Now I'm gonna ask Kiro
to build the application
and run it locally.
So the Kiro is actually doing
the build, it checks the
dependency, so it checks what
.net version I'm running on
the local computer.
It finds that it's already running nine.
Then it tries to restore all
the, it runs the .net restore
all the dependencies, everything.
It started building the application.
So you can see the build has succeeded.
So it has provided me a URL saying
that it's listening on port 8080.
So I click on the URL, it opens
the .net, the application,
the Unicorn application.
Now I can go in, choose
Unicorns that I want
to purchase from the store
and then click on summit.
So as you can see, this was
the previous application demo
that that Anand has showed.
Right now it is running on .net eight.
But key thing to remember
here is we haven't
decomposed this application.
So it is still running as a monolith app,
but it's version has been
upgraded to .net eight.
Now let me call Anand on stage
to explain on the
decomposition process, right?
- Thanks, Sree.
So what we, so far that
we have application
and now to perform the
analysis, how we can
decompose our Unicorn
store application, right?
So what we have covered
from our seven step process,
the step number one, two, and three,
we have completed, we have
done the application analysis,
we have done the
transformation of the code,
and then we have also validated
that application is successfully working
after the transformation.
Now we need to look upon
the decomposition analysis
to identify the probable right candidate
of the microservices, right?
And trust me folks, this
is the toughest part.
How do we break a monolithic
application into the more
modular decoupled application, right?
So how do we break it?
There are different ways
in which we have observed
the application team, the
application owner, you know, try
to decompose the existing
monolith application into the more
decoupled microservices based architecture
and they fall into a different pitfall.
Now what are those pitfalls?
The very first pitfall is
the distributed monolithic.
Often the time we have seen
the application owners,
they converge to the
distributed monolithic.
How?
Because they try to apply
a horizontal tiering
to the existing monolithic application.
What does it mean?
It means grouping the related
functionally related modules
together, which are similar or
the common component together
and try to carve out a sub modules
or the subgroup out of your
monolithic application.
You have a monolithic application,
you're grouping the
related component together
and what you have is a smaller
submodules coming out from
that application, but still
they are doing multiple thing
or more than one thing and they
are inheriting the property,
the design challenges of
monolithic applications, right?
The other pitfall which we are
seeing the application team
goes into is a nano service.
What does it mean?
It happens due to the vertical
tearing of the application.
Now what the vertical tearing
of the application means?
Let's say you have a UI
and the business capability
driven by those UI pages.
What the application owner
try to do, they try to break
or split the application
functionalities using
the different UI screens what they have.
Now, imagine the situation if
your monolithic application
comprises of the hundreds of UI pages.
Now what could eventually
end up happening?
You are having those many number
of nano services in
your environment, right?
And then it impose lot
of operational challenges
because you need to take
care of hundreds of services
and it also increase the check
in your environment, right?
So these are the common pitfall
and that is where the right granularity
is the key to decompose these existing
monolithic applications.
Another question comes, how do I arrive
to the right granularity, right?
And that is where the key
here is to not only assist
or analyze the existing
monolithic applications from the
implementation, from the
technology perspective,
but also to have the right analysis done
from the business domain perspective
and then combine the
right business analysis
and the technical analysis
together to arrive
to this right granularity, right?
How do we achieve that?
So there are some
architectural methodologies
which we are going to talk
about, which can help us
to arrive to the right granularity.
One of them is the domain-driven design.
First spoke by the Eric Ewan
and what he mentioned that the
technology is not important,
not the primary focus, should
not be the primary focus
for the software development.
Rather the business features
and the capabilities
which we want to perform
through the technology
should be the primary focus.
And what does it mean?
So the domain driven
design help us to arrive
the shared understanding
from the business owners
and the application
owners together so that
we can build the right software,
applying the right granularity
and the right architectural
patterns, right?
This is what the domain
driven design provide us
and how domain driven design works.
Let's look into some of its
some of its key concepts.
So what is domain,
the domain driven design help
us to do a right analysis
of the given application
from the domain perspective
and help us to understand the domain
and its different boundaries.
So domain could be a business
for which we want to work
and provide the services
to our end customer.
In our use case for Unicorn
store, the retail is a domain
because the e-commerce
application running over the web
and providing the different
capabilities to the end user.
Now this retail could have
a different sub-domains.
For example, the order
management module, right?
It's a sub-domain which help us
to manage the overall
orders for our application.
The second could be the
fulfillment once the order are
placed, how the fulfillment
of those orders happen
and the shipment of course, so
that you know these
products which are purchased
by the end users, you know
can be delivered to them.
So these could be a subdomains
for a given domain.
Now, in that this subdomain
further need to be categorized
into the three different categories.
One of them is the core subdomain.
What does the core subdomain means?
The core subdomain means the subdomain,
which is a differentiator for you, right?
Which is what you should
care about to modernize,
which consists of your
business logic, right?
In our case, it is the order management
for fit management and
the shipment management.
The second subdomain type
is a supporting subdomain.
Supporting subdomain are
required for the core domain
to achieve its functionality.
Take an example for a order management,
you might be running some loyalty program
and that might for that the
user information might have
to come from the the CRM system.
So, the supporting subdomains
other domain which sometime
can be built or sometime can be bought
as external software products.
The last is the generic subdomain.
For example, if any user
has to purchase any product,
they need to first authenticate
and have a right access
to the application.
And the genAI subdomain
could be our identity system,
which often be buy bought,
not the build, right?
Because that's not the core domain
for the retail application, right?
So if we just focus on the core subdomain
in the context of our Unicorn application,
the core subdomain will again
have a different context
within it, right?
Which help us to provide the
right business capabilities
around their subdomain.
In case of order subdomain
the order subdomain
have a different context
because order required items,
order requires the end users
who purchase those items
and then the payment which has been,
so there are different context associated
with it within their subdomain.
Same could be in the case
of the fulfillment subdomain
as well.
So this domain domain
design help helping you
to assess the right
analysis of the domain.
It's subdomain.
What is the core subdomain?
And the core subdomain is comprising of
what different context.
And eventually this context will help you
to define the right boundaries
around these subdomain
and those boundaries will
then finally converge into the
right services, right?
And we will see how this happens, right?
But the questions comes, okay,
the domain driven design is good
because it is helping you to come
to the common understanding
between the business owners
and the application owners.
But how should I start
understanding these sub-domains?
How should I start getting
this information about
this different context?
And that is where the Alberto Brandolini,
he's inventor of Event storming,
made a very good quote,
"What become the software
is not the expert knowledge,
but the developer's understanding,"
or sometime the misunderstanding
because the business owners mean
what understanding business owners have.
The application owners may not
have the same understanding.
And that's where we have to bring both
of these parties together
so that they understand the domain
in the shared context, right?
And that is where the Event storming as a
next architecture methodologies
can help to achieve
the business owners and
the application owners
to have their shared
understanding of the domain.
How this happen.
The Event Storming is not
a any architectural tool
or the design pattern,
it's a methodologies,
it's a workshop which happens
between the business owners
and the application owners.
And the intent of the workshop is
to understand the domain via
identifying the different
domain events and identify
that these domain events
producers and consumers.
And once we identify that,
then we can identify the different
bounded contexts associated
with those subdomains
and then those bounded
contexts eventually become the
blueprint for the different services.
So how this event is storming happen,
even the storming has a different elements
and the intent of the workshop is
the event storm exercise
to identify these six
or seven elements which are
represented by, represented
by the different multicolor sticky notes.
So how this happen, the first sticky note
or the first element is the domain event.
We identify what are the
different domain event are part of
the given domain special
in our case, for example,
order created, order canceled
or order placed are these
different type of event.
Events are always
represented in the past tense
means something has happened
in your business context.
The second key element to
identify under the event storm
exercises, the command,
like what commands generated this event.
For example, somebody would've
placed a command, okay,
place order or cancel my order.
So these commands are eventually
generating those events.
The third thing to
identify who are the actors
who are actually issuing those command.
In our Unicorn store
use case, I'm the user,
I'm logging to the application
and I'm placing those commands.
It could be the machine as well,
it could be business processes
as well who can become
as an actor who are issuing
the different commands.
The fourth key element is aggregate.
Aggregate is something who
actually understand these command
and execute certain business
logic to fulfill those command.
The next one is the business policies.
So as part of the event storming,
we identify the different
business policies.
And the business policies
could be like when somebody is
placing the order, whether the
inventory has been validated,
whether the payment is
successfully done or not,
before even placing
the order successfully.
So these are the business validation rule
which will apply for the
different business flows.
The next is the external system.
For example, if I'm
placing the order, I need
to perform a payment first
and for payment I might be leveraging
the external payment gateway.
So what are the external
component which are involved in my
business processes, right?
And last but not the least, the view
which is represented in form
of let's say a UI screen
where the user can then
understand the current state
of the application or
the business and then
accordingly take the action like
or understand, okay, whether
my order is placed by
whether my order order is
shipped or it has been canceled.
It could be anything for that matter.
And if we identify all these elements,
then we arrive to the domain event driven
decomposition approach.
So it's a domain events who
drive the decomposition.
So the applying the domain
driven design principle along
with the event storming can help us
to identify the
microservices-based architecture.
How this happened.
We perform the domain analysis,
we apply the event storming
to further advance the domain analysis
with more bounded context
specific information,
identify the right bounded context,
and then from there converse
to the right microservice.
If I take example of the order
management, how the outcome
of the event is storming for the order
processing use case might look like.
So I'm actor as a user who is performing
a command saying that place order.
That command produce a domain
event like order is created.
And when when this event is created,
there are some business
policies which are getting
validated, like validated
the inventory, right?
And based on the inventory only you
successfully place the order.
And once that is done,
then it could again
issue a separate commands
and there could be external systems
and like a payment gateway, right?
They can also produce the events like
the payment is successful.
Now, once we do this
event storming analysis,
do identification of these
different sticky notes
and different domain event,
and then what we do, we try
to group the relevant related
domain even together and then converge to
the right bounded context
and that right bounded context
then represent the different
domain services for us.
So in this example, for the
order processing use case,
what we saw the the entire
event is streaming analysis
help us to identify what are some of
the application capabilities in terms of
what command it could support
the order management flow,
what are some of its external system
to which it depend upon like payment
and what are its own
repository means the data which
or the current state which
it need to maintain in terms
of the order lifecycle.
So this is how we can actually perform
the right decomposition for a
given monolithic application
with the right granularity.
And now let's see how Jenny, I can help us
to accelerate this entire event storming
and the domain driven
design based analysis
for our given application.
So we again leverage the Kiro here.
We have already done the transformation of
our uni store application
to the .net eight.
Now what we use, we ask Kiro
to perform the event
storming analysis for us.
So we provide a prompt.
In the prompt we tell Kiro do
the event storming analysis
and identify all these seven element
of event storming from
the events to the commands
to the actor external
system business policies
and the aggregates.
And the Kiro then introspect
the entire application code
base and it tries to identify all these
event storming elements
and then try to map what
could be the, you know,
the probable bounded context
which can be faced using
this event storming analysis, right?
So currently Kiro is
performing that analysis
and it has done its analysis
and now we can see
what are the different
domain event which has been
identified by Kiro for
a given application.
So if we highlight on that, can we see
for example the order
management event, order created,
order completed, order failed,
or the even the payment process, right?
In case of shopping cart.
Also, there are different
type of domain events
which has been identified.
Now the intent here is not
to do a complete event storming
and domain event analysis
based on the journey I,
but this information
certainly become the base
on which further the business owner
and the application owners
can do their own assessment
and refine it further.
And we are seeing that not
only the domain events,
the different commands
and different aggregates, all
of those has been identified
by Kiro for a given
monolithic application, right?
Unicorn story in our case, right?
So not only it's just
identifying the domain event,
it is going one step beyond
and then it is also giving us
those probable bounded context
and also highlighting the
probable microservices,
which could be carve out
from this given legacy
monolithic application.
So, this is important, folks,
because this recommendation
is now not just coming
from those horizontal tearing
or the vertical tearing,
which we saw it is coming from
the architectural methodologies
like domain driven
design and even storming,
which has been applied
and working backward from there,
what could be the
probable boundary context
and the respective microservices?
Now we have done this analysis.
The next thing is, as I
mentioned, to actually perform
this event is coming
where the outcome of this
Kiro become the base
for the business owner
and application owner.
And they can go into the
shared work workshop mode
to further optimize this analysis
and then modify it according
to their business understanding
and the implementation understanding.
And this even storming
workshop can happen in person
or it can happen virtually.
We are taking a use case where
it has to happen virtually.
There are some platforms
which provides the virtual
event storming board.
One of such platform is Miro.
So Miro help us to do a
virtual event storming exercise
via providing the virtual
event storming board
and IT support these
different sticky notes,
what we talked about.
So for that, what are the
prerequisite as a developer,
you can create a developer account,
the API keys are generated,
and using those API keys,
you can then, you know,
programmatically generate the
different even storming board.
And exactly the same thing we want to do.
And again, we are leveraging
the genAI capability
to perform the same.
So what we are asking
Kiro, okay, based on this
event storming analysis,
which has been done,
generate a script, which then can
create a mirror board for us
and apply all this understanding
what we have got via
event installing analysis
on this Unicorn store application.
So Kiro goes ahead
and actually generate the script, right?
And with that script,
it is going to generate
a virtual event storming
board for all of us.
And the intent would be then
we use that virtual board
and then the product owner
and the application owner can
do their further brainstorming
and optimize or refine the
different service boundaries
and the bounded context
accordingly, right?
So it has done the, it has
created the board successfully.
And then we will quickly see how
that board looks like with
a different bounded context.
So it takes us to the Miro platform
and then we open the Miro board.
And if we can see, this is how
all the different domain events,
it's associated commands,
it's associated the business
policies, external systems,
how they have been grouped together
in the different context.
We are just taking example
of zooming into the
order management domain.
If we see how the bounded context
for the order management has been built,
right via genAI capabilities to
after performing the event storming
and domain driven design based analysis.
So we have all the different
events from the order
processing flow in place.
We have all this respective commands,
we have all this
respective external system
and the other element part of it.
Now this become the blueprint
for us to then build
the right microservices
with the right boundaries
and the granularity.
Now, for us, the next phase
is to see now based on this
these bounded context,
what we have generated,
how we can then refine the architecture
for our monolithic application
and then build these new
microservices, which we have seen
as part of the event
storming outcome in form
of those different bounded contexts.
So for that I call Sree. Sree over to you.
- I also want to explain what the MCP is.
So MCP is an open source
protocol that standardizes
how application talks to
large language models,
providing them with the right context.
Now if you look at the bottom
of the slide, you have the MCP
on the left side you have the agents.
So these agents could be
chatbots, autonomous workflows
or your application.
On the right you have data sources,
which could be your
APIs, internal systems,
databases, et cetera.
So MCP sits right in the
middle. So it's access a glue.
So instead of an agent integrating
with every system in its own custom way.
MCP gives you a common
consistent way to describe
and tools and share data.
So this means that the
agents become more portable,
integrations are usable,
and then you don't have to,
you can avoid the one-off
plumping that every time
that you have to do when a new
agent talks to a new source
or you want a new capability.
Now AWS has
a GitHub rapport where we have
provided a lot of reusable MCP servers.
So one of the MCP server
that we will be using here is
the AWS architecture diagram, MCP server.
It's a Python package
and it helps you to design
architecture diagrams,
flow diagrams, sequence
diagrams, et cetera.
So we'll be calling that MCP server.
So the next step is basically
for you to go into Kiro
and configure the MCP server.
It's a very simple step.
You go to GitHub, you get the MCP server,
the instructions that you need to follow
to add the MCP server into your
ID is mentioned over there.
So once you've configured that,
so I have already done it,
now I'm asking Kiro
to generate an architecture
diagram for me.
So again, by default it
creates a PNG diagram
or a JPEG diagram, right?
But I want something
that, I want to iterate,
I want to modify.
So I use a tool called
draw.io very frequently.
So what I'm telling Kiro is to generate
that architecture diagram
in a draw.io XML format.
So then it would be easier for me
to start iterating from here.
So let's go ahead and play the demo.
So I'm going to ask Kiro, use
the AWS diagram MCP server
to create a draw.io XML diagram
showing AWS microservices
architecture based on the bonded context
that has been identified
from the previous session.
So it's gonna call the MCP server.
You can see that it has called
the MCP tool, Get_diagram
and then it's gonna generate
the architecture diagram
for me.
So it has actually
generated a PNG diagram.
Since I have asked for a
draw.io, it's actually going
to recreate that file in draw.io.
So also if we have noticed
on the left hand side,
it has created that
particular file, right?
It has created the architecture diagram,
data flow patterns all
are defined over there.
So I have opened my draw.io.
So I'm going to open the
diagram that it has created.
Yeah, see this is created
by the MCP server directly.
So earlier this used to
take days for an admin
to be both a platform architect
or application owner to create it.
Now it has already been
done through the MCP server.
Now this, you can see that
it's actually organized
based on different domains.
So you have user management
domain, product catalog domain,
how the different data
flows works each other.
Again, there is Lambda
mentioned over there,
but it is easily replaceable
since it's microservice.
You can either replace it
with an ECS or any case
or a container solution.
It has also identified
the external services
where notifications like ECS,
third party APIs, it needs
to call the monitoring
and the logging capability
as well in the architecture diagram.
So this is a raw diagram that
has been created by Kiro.
Now again, you can iterate it
based on your requirements.
Okay, so next step, the
seventh that we have seen
next step is to actually decompose
and refactor this entire application into
microservices with Kiro.
Now going to ask Kiro
to actually break down
this monolith code into
different microservices.
So I'm gonna prompt Kiro now.
So I'm going to ask it to analyze
and decompose it to microservices.
I'm also asking it to generate web APIs,
entity framework, models,
database, data components,
everything separately.
So it has done the analysis,
it has completed the extraction
of the microservices.
So you can see that it has created
a comprehensive project structure.
So independent service
folders, shared artifacts,
Kubernetes manifest, and
deployment files, right?
So you can we'll explore the
folders, the service folders
and shared artifact on the left hand side.
So you can see that I know
the project structure.
So the services are organized
as catalog, cart, order, user.
And if we explore the folder structure
on the left hand side,
you can see the services, the cart.
So it can also identify the
service contracts between APIs.
It can identify data ownership
issues between services.
It can identify shared code
which it needs to extract
as common libraries.
So it'll identify all those.
So you can see that earlier
you saw the project files
actually organized under one folder.
If you remember the first
slide that we showed, right?
Now you can see that
it has been organized.
The project files has been organized into
different folder structure.
So I'm just running through
each of those folders
to make sure that all the files are here.
Again, it has created the
deployment files as well.
So depending on the
platform that you're asking.
So in this prompt that I gave, I asked it
to create a deployment file for Kubernetes
or EKS deployment.
So it has created me a
cloud formation template,
which I can then use to
deploy the infrastructure
and the application components
for that application.
Alright? Okay.
So let me invite Anand also to summarize
the modernization flow.
- Hey thanks, Sree.
So finally what we have achieved, right?
We started with the legacy
monolithic application
and we have run through
the seven step process
to modernize this Unicorn
store application.
So first we did the code
analysis leveraging the Kiro,
then we transformed the
from .net older framework
to .net eight for our
existing application using
AWS transform.
And then what we did, we
actually did the event storming
and domain driven analysis for
a given application, right?
And then we generated
a different event board
to represent a different bounded contest
we could arrive to with
the right granularity,
which then finally converge
into the right microservices
or the right services.
And then from there,
and this, we did it all
through the Kiro and we
leverage MCP integration of Kiro
to then generate the architectural diagram
for these new microservices.
And then we finally decompose
our legacy monolithic application
and refactor that into the more modern
microservices-based
architecture, again using Kiro.
So the end-to-end journey of modernization
has been accelerated using
our genAI-based capabilities
along with the different
architectural methodologies
and the practices, right?
So what are some of the key takeaways?
One of the key takeaways
definitely leveraging
the domain domain design
and the event storming
based approach to do a right analysis
of your domain and then get
the right shared understanding
between the application
owner and the business owners
to define the right boundaries
and the granularities,
to decompose the legacy applications.
Sorry, the second is on
leveraging AI based capabilities
like AWS transforming Kiro
to accelerate your modernization
and which can significantly
reduce your overall effort,
time, and the cost to modernize
your legacy application stack, right?
And you can drive the innovation faster.
So that's all, folks, thank you very much
for joining our session.
And if you have any queries,
me and Sree are down there
and we can take your
queries if you have any.
Thank you.
- [Sree] Thank you. Thanks, everyone.